آلان شيبنك هو كاتب حاصل على جوائز
ويغطي اللعبة لأكثر من 20
عامًا.
دان رابابورت هو كاتب فريق العمل في لعبة غولف
ديستيج الذي بنى سمعة كواحد
من الكتاب الأوائل في اللعبة.
من هذا
الضخم التاريخي دان ألين هنا ، نحن موطن لعبة الجولف ،
لماذا هو مميز
جدًا ، هذا هو المكان الذي بدأ فيه كل شيء بشكل
صحيح وهناك فقط خلود لهذه
المدينة في هذه الدورة وبغض النظر عن عدد
المرات التي كنت فيها هنا أو مدى السخرية
قد لا تكون هناك ، فقط لديك
شعور خاص
وهذه الدورة على الرغم من أنها تبدو غريبة
وعشوائية ، إلا أنك تنظر إلى قائمة
الفائزين ، إلا أنها تنتج أبطالًا عظماء ،
أعني حقًا
كما قال روري ، أعني أن هذا هو
ذروة الرياضة وهذا  هو ما يريده كل
لاعب غولف ويحتاجه لإكمال
مسيرته ، لذلك هناك طاقة إضافية
هنا أعتقد في لعبة الجولف ، تنظر إلى
ما قاله الأساطير عن
مكان يحمل وزنًا ، وقال جاك نيكلوس إنه
لا توجد مهنة مشتركة  mplete ما لم تربح في سانت أندروز تايجر يقدس
المكان وأعتقد أنه عندما يحتل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
كانوا مهمين جدًا في تطوير
لعبة الجولف وتطوير
التاريخ هذا المكان في مثل هذا التقدير العالي
أعتقد أن هذا النوع من الصدى يتردد
في جميع أنحاء عالم الجولف
أنا أحب أن لعبة الجولف هي مركز هذه
المدينة ولا يتعين عليك الاعتذار
لكونك من الجوزاء الذين أعيش في بروكلين
نيويورك ، ويبدو الأمر كما لو
أن الخليج ليس جزءًا من
الحياة اليومية هنا تتجول فيها وكل
كل حانة ذات طابع لعبة الجولف ، وهناك متاجر للجولف في
كل مكان ، يوجد كل
شخص تراه أشخاصًا لديهم
نوادي على أكتافهم تعلمون أنهم
يلتقطون الحليب أو يذهبون إلى
طبيب الأسنان ، إنه مجرد الجولف هو جزء مركزي
من هذه
المدينة وبالطبع هناك مجتمعات  في
الولايات المتحدة وحول العالم حيث يكون
هذا هو الحال ولكن الأمر مختلف هنا
إنه جزء من النسيج الذي أعتقد
أنه مجرد جانب فريد حقًا
وهنا نحن النمر المفتوح رقم 150
وقد أطلق عليه اسم العظيم
منفتحًا ، سنلعب في
هل تشعر بالخصوصية الإضافية بنسبة مليون في
المائة ، وأعتقد أن سياق ما
يحدث في لعبة الجولف في
الوقت الحالي يجعل الأمر أكثر
خصوصية لأن
الكثير من الحوار حول  لقد كان
العامان الماضيان حقًا يتعلقان
بالمال والمال والمزيد من المال ، ويبدو أن
هذا الأسبوع
كل شخص يضع ذلك جانبًا
ويشارك فقط في هذا التقدير
لهذا المكان الخاص والمناسبة الخاصة ،
أعني 150 عامًا
بالنسبة لنا نحن الأمريكيين ، أعني هذا
هذا صعب للغاية لفهمه خاصة
بعد اليوبيل الخاص بالملكة ،
فالجميع يحب الذكرى السنوية ،
وهو يضع نقطة جيدة حول كيفية تحديد هذه
البطولة وهذه
الدورة للرياضة بأكملها ،
لذا فأنا أعيش في كاليفورنيا ،
وهناك الكثير من المباني  أليست
قديمة هناك الدولة بالكاد تأسست
منذ 150 عامًا ، لذا
فهي بالتأكيد تقود ، لذلك نحن في
المسار القديم ، كم هو العمر جيدًا ، إنه
حقًا قديم و 150 عامًا
تعرف على البطولات المفتوحة بأنها
هائلة
وهي بالتأكيد تكلفة للاحتفال
[موسيقى]